este año pintaba muy bien
éste iba a ser el verano más bonito de
mi vida
y yo no tenía que estar aquí hoy
yo tenía que estar ahora
agotada por el calor hinchada apenas
pudiendo moverme
esperando a que mi hija me diera la
señal de estaría preparada para conocer
a sus padres y a toda esa gente que
tantas ganas tenía de darle la
bienvenida
hace unos meses sufrió un aborto tardío
la hija que estaba esperando murió
el duelo de pérdida gestacional es uno
de los duelos más invisibles e
incomprendidos que la mayoría de las
mujeres viven en silencio en soledad
soy psicóloga terapeuta y formadora a lo
largo de los últimos años pude conocer
cientos de testimonios de personas con
las que trabaje sobre sus vivencias de
dolor de tristeza
de duelo pero no fue hasta el momento de
tener que afrontar la realidad personal
de perdida cuando emergió en mí la
necesidad de hacer una reflexión más
amplia y profunda sobre el espacio que
damos en esta cultura a las experiencias
emocionalmente difíciles
en mi duelo me es en el sentido
sostenida y acompañada sin embargo
también he conocido la otra parte del
duelo la que conocía también de los
relatos de mis clientes de mis alumnos
de los asistentes de mis talleres porque
a lo largo de los últimos meses también
he recibido comentarios y mensajes que
en lugar de hacerme sentir más
acompañada más apoyada me hacían sentir
más aislada más sola a veces hasta
inadecuada o exagerada
hablo de momentos que cuando en una
conversación o un saludo entre dos
personas se produce cierta cierta
torpeza o incomodidad por las dos partes
la torpeza de la persona que quiere
expresar su apoyo pero no encuentra las
palabras adecuadas y mi propia torpeza
al no ser capaz de decirle que lo que me
está diciendo no me sirve y en el mejor
de los casos me hace desconectar
y sé que todos tenemos buenas
intenciones
cuando sufrimos mucho
no tenemos energía suficiente ni interés
para indicar a los demás como que pueden
hacer o dejar de hacer para que su ayuda
sea útil sea eficaz
hoy cuando mi dolor ha disminuido si me
siento capaz de expresar sin pelos en la
lengua porque ciertos comentarios no
ayudan
quiero ofrecer propuestas para que
podamos a las buenas intenciones añadir
también un trato empático
creo que el mensaje que deseo compartir
hoy es importante para todos porque
todos vamos a vivir algún día una
experiencia difícil una experiencia de
duelo de dolor emocional y todos vamos a
acompañar a alguien que está en un
momento de dolor estremecedor de pérdida
de efecto afectiva de un diagnóstico
médico no favorable de un cambio vital
brusco e inesperado
así que qué mensaje es mejor evitar si
lo que buscamos es una conexión
verdadera con la persona
en mi caso uno de los mensajes que más
daño me hacía era el no te preocupes ya
verás que pronto te vas a quedar
embarazada otra vez
este mensaje tenía como objetivo sacarme
distraerme del duelo del dolor del
momento presente y llevarme al futuro
donde las cosas parece que siempre van
mejor
pero cuando ocurre algo tan difícil la
vida se para y el futuro se vuelve
irrelevante
a hablar de futuro a una persona que
acaba de sufrir una pérdida es hablarle
de una dimensión a la que temporalmente
no tiene acceso su sufrimiento
está en el aquí y ahora y es la única
realidad que existe y que necesita ser
abrazada
así que no le digas a una persona que
sufre que todo va a salir bien dile que
estás con ella aquí y ahora y que ves lo
mucho que está sufriendo
no compares las vivencias ni minimice es
la pérdida cada perdida se merece su
reconocimiento se merece ser vista y
llorado no hay un acontecimiento una
experiencia concreta a partir de la cual
el dolor y la queja empiezan a ser
justificados
no le obligue a relativizar a una
persona que sufre no busques el lado
positivo de lo ocurrido no le digas que
tiene que estar agradecida por lo que
tiene
no le ofrezcas que te llame si necesita
algo porque probablemente no va a llamar
y en una época donde primero mandamos un
mensaje para preguntar a la persona así
la podemos llamar
llámala sin pedir permiso
y no te enfades si no lo coge pero no
esperes que sea ella la que dé el primer
paso
no le digas que te duele verla llorar
hay algo muy violento en las palabras no
quiero ver de triste es una presión
si te incomodan las lágrimas y la
desesperación de otra persona
probablemente vives alejado de tu propia
vulnerabilidad y de tu propia impotencia
no le digas que sea fuerte y que deje de
llorar llorar y ser fuerte no se
excluyen sentirse abatido y ser fuerte
no se excluyen
no tener temporalmente interés por vivir
y ser fuerte no se excluyen
cuando muere alguien cercano sobre todo
si es una muerte inesperada muchas veces
los dolientes reciben de su entorno la
explicación que le da sentido a lo
ocurrido
en el caso de mi aborto las
explicaciones más comunes fueron
las explicaciones más comunes fueron la
naturaleza es sabia porque no tenía que
ser tu hija está en un lugar mejor dios
necesitaba otro ángel o es que trabajas
mucho a lo mejor no descansaba lo
suficiente
tener una explicación por muy absurda
ingenua o culpabilizan te que sea nos da
la ilusión de seguridad nos permite
pensar que la vida que el mundo es un
lugar previsible y que todo pasa por
algo
nos sentimos muy vulnerables cuando
ocurre algo a lo que no podemos darle
una explicación
preferimos nutrirnos de frases hechas
para no tener que hacer frente a la
incertidumbre del destino
y tea y frases tipo
necesitamos esa experiencia para crecer
como persona
o para ser mejor terapeuta o lo que no
te mata te hará más fuerte
ninguna de esas frases tiene porqué ser
cierta y los dolientes no las
necesitamos
lo más curioso de todos esos mensajes es
que esconden las ideas socialmente
compartidas sobre el duelo sobre la
tristeza sobre el dolor cuando hagas a
una persona doliente un comentario
desafortunado no te culpes por ello
porque hay ideas que hemos heredado
todos
son ideas que vienen de la necesidad que
compartimos todos los seres humanos de
alejarnos de lo que no entendemos y de
lo que encontramos amenazante para
nuestro bienestar
los mensajes implícitos que reciben las
personas que sufren muchas veces
implican que tienen que hacer algo para
que no duela
o para que duela menos o para que deje
de doler cuanto antes
y de ahí vienen los consejos que nos
invitan a distraernos a no preocuparnos
a no darle más vuelta a lo ocurrido y
avanzar
no queremos escuchar sobre el dolor de
los demás porque nos obliga a darnos
cuenta que al pertenecer a la misma
especie las cosas difíciles también nos
pueden pasar a nosotros
en algún momento casi todos empezamos a
creer que la vida bien vivida es la vida
de emociones positivas
que si algo es incómodo significa que
está mal y deberíamos eliminar o
corregir lo que lo incómodo es un
problema a resolver
y en un mundo orientado a buscar
soluciones se nos olvida que no todo lo
incómodo necesita ser solucionado que
hay experiencias que tienen que ser
vividas y aprendidas sin más
y en un mundo orientado a la
productividad y a los resultados nos
cuesta acompañar simplemente desde el
estar desde ser sin hacer
probablemente
si de pequeños vimos a nuestros padres
ocultar sus lágrimas su tristeza su
impotencia
o si en algún momento nuestro dolor fue
ridiculizado ignorado o comparado esto
hace que nos cueste ver el dolor como lo
que es una experiencia un fenómeno
emocional común que no necesita arreglo
solo necesita atención y presencia
un niño que llora porque se acaba de
caer de la bici no necesita un
chupa-chups para distraerse del dolor
solo necesita un testigo un testigo
empático de esa experiencia la idea de
que tenemos que distraernos del dolor y
de las emociones incómodas está presente
en las adicciones en el abuso de las
sustancias psicoactivas en las conductas
autodestructivas
cuando sufrimos
no necesitamos que alguien nos rescate
que nos distraiga que nos salve de
nuestro dolor no necesitamos consejos ni
explicaciones solo necesitamos que
nuestro dolor sea visto que se ha
reconocido y validado aceptado y
abrazado
cuando la gente me pregunta que decir
cuando no saben qué decir les explico
que no saber qué decir no es una
manifestación de falta de habilidades
sociales sino de una sabiduría profunda
que nos dice que a lo mejor no toca
decir nada que a lo mejor toca escuchar
o toca estar en silencio
o toca dar un abrazo entregado
toca estar
todos vamos a vivir situaciones
difíciles pero no tenemos por qué vivir
las escondidas en silencio en soledad la
tristeza es una emoción que para su
correcta gestión necesita ser compartida
necesita ser vivida en compañía
y reconocer nuestro dolor es mucho más
fácil cuando social y culturalmente se
crea espacio para ver lo difícil como
una parte más de la vida
cuando estés con una persona que sufre
no busques palabras que disminuyan la
aflicción haz que sienta tu presencia y
tu permiso para vivirlo a su manera que
siempre es la correcta
gracias